two days ago a Strike Team assassinated
President Udo
and yet you cannot prove that we weren't
involved doesn't that concern you no sir
it terrifies me
you need to manage this Jack yes sir
what are you going to tell them this
corruption goes way higher than the CIA
hey buddy say welcome I figured we could
use the help wish me luck
good luck
[Music]
give me everything you can I'm Domingo
Chavez
on paper you might be the deadliest
operator the cia's ever employed I need
to find out who's behind all this to be
honest with you you're all I've got
see this
now I'm blushing
so what are we getting at convergence
the fusing of a drug cartel with a
terrorist organization
they can move anything humans weapons
suicide bombers unlimited resources
paired with undying hatred
[Music]
not on my watch
the world is a game board of changing
hands
oh
nothing but vipers Beyond these walls
you do not know who these people are
sure I'll meet him soon enough
[Music]
jackets out there risking his life
I always wanted to be a federal Ally
It's the CIA of a second fourth
sure you want to know
what do you say he hung up on me typical
him
[Applause]